hi everyone my name's
paul wiseman i'm a professor of
chemistry and physics at mcgill
university
and uh today i'm going to talk to you
about
spatial temporal image correlation
spectroscopy how this
can be used to effectively mine images
for
biomolecule information inside of
themselves
i hope everyone's doing it well during
these challenging times
i would like to first of all thank the
organizers for inviting me to present
the cell inventor developmental biology
virtual meeting
and let's get into
the uh the talk in terms of
overview what i'm going to talk about
today i'm going to give an introduction
or background
on spatial temporal image relations
microscopy
methods from which it was developed how
one would actually carry out this
analysis
what's important to understand in order
to extract molecular
information i then am going to provide
two research applications one involves a
combination of super resolution
imaging looking at acting dynamics in
lymphocytes
and studying aspects of organization
of artificial immune synapses in the
lymphocytes
secondly i'm going to present a range of
correlation
spectroscopy analysis on dynamics
protozoans
in live human immune dendritic cells
and both of these are collaborations and
i will highlight the
uh the collaboration partners
for their important contributions and
actually driving this work
first now the introduction or background
the image correlation techniques are
built on what are generally known as
fluorescence fluctuation
methods the original
fluorescence fluctuation method was
called fluorescence correlation
spectroscopy
or fcs was developed in the early 1970s
by ellie nelson walt webb and douglas
magdy at
cornell university and the basic idea
behind the method was to focus the laser
beam through
a microscope objective into a sample
this hourglass
is meant to represent the focus beam the
focus defines a small observation volume
and then fluorescent molecules as they
randomly
move in and out by diffusion can be
excited
and uh while they're within the beam
focus
and this fluorescence is back collected
through the same object objective onto a
point detector
put a mul put a multiplier tubes on the
original
systems more commonly on modern
instruments
avalanche photodiodes for the point
detectors
now these fluorescence intensity
signal can be characterized in time and
calculate it as fluctuations from a mean
as i'll explain later
and we can look at a time series here
fluorescence fluctuation
as a function of time and we see
the fluctuating signal over time this
time series can be
statistically characterized by a time
correlation function
g of tau tau is a time shift or time
length variable
how does the fluctuation at time t
compare
the magnitude at a displaced time
t plus tau normalize this by the average
intensity squared
and map this over all time legs
at low time legs you have high
correlation because
at short times nothing has had a chance
to move or decorate
as time lag increases you decorate
and you get sorry you get a decay
due to the transport of the molecules in
and out of the focus
so a fit of this decay with an
appropriate fit model can be used to
extrane
extract diffusion coefficients and other
transport coefficients
the zero leg or amplitude of correlation
function
is actually inverse proportional to the
mean number of molecules in the focus
and that is characteristic of the
amplitude information
which is also obtained from this
correlation analysis
now one can extend the correlation
spectroscopy analysis to two color
or fluorescence cross correlation
spectroscopy as with pioneered
by petra schweiler and here you label
two different
biomolecules with a green and a red
label for example
and you collect both signals from
equivalent focal volume
in the same point and you look at the
cross-fluctuating signals
and characterize them by
cross-correlation function this gives
transport dynamics for the co-localized
species
and from the amplitude analysis of the
zero light values you can get
fractions of interacting volumes uh
interacting molecules
now the fcs method and the fccs method
on the basis of from which the image
correlation methods were developed
but we now extend to the imaging
platform
to extract more information uh from
these types of systems and specifically
we're interested in cells
when one moves to looking at image
correlation spectroscopy it becomes
important to understand what type of
imaging system are you using
what is the point spread function pixel
dimensions
time step and specifically how
is the light focused so here
i'm showing uh an image from a laser
scanning microscope
gfp tagged sample and this
grid is meant to represent that image
with the
central value in green being some
numerical intensity value recorded
at that position in terms of the image
however
this pixel is not in isolation for this
standard resolution
lsm here i show a gaussian beam
showing the spatial extent of the focus
uh for this
this instrument and here laterally is
the
it's the x x y
point spread function effectively and
here we have
the pixel but note that the focal volume
or the focal area of the point spread
function
extends or over space
and we encompass information over a
range
of pixels in space in other words
adjacent pixels have correlated
intensity information
due to the actual focal size
for the given microscope so for any of
these methods it becomes important to
characterize the point spread function
to understand what type of microscopy
are we doing
is it laser scanning microscope is it
total internal reflection are we looking
at
membrane components in 2v is it a 3d
system
and we need to characterize our focal
parameters laterally and axially
accordingly to extract quantitative
information
it's also important in knowing if the in
if the microscope is well aligned
given this from the images we can then
obtain
different types of fluctuation
information the image series and time
will contain temporal fluctuations
on a slow time scale uh similar to what
we looked at
in fcs basically we're looking at
residency time in a given region
where characteristic fluctuation time
reflects the underlying transport
however the images also give us access
to spatial fluctuations so here
we see cartoon lateral
focus point spread function integrating
from
two dye molecules and if we move over
this area is integrating from three
there's going to be a fluctuation
difference between these two that
information shows up in spatial
fluctuations which can be analyzed
through an autocorrelation analysis
as with fcs but now we're going to
incorporate space
as well as time so
what it is the definition of a
fluctuation formula
it's the value at a given point
intensity at a given point in space and
time
minus the average intensity so delta i
is the fluctuation value minus the mean
and this is what is inputted for
correlation analysis
now given a series of images
obtained on some type of microscope we
can choose different types of
correlation analysis depending what
we're interested in
the very first publication on
image correlation spectroscopy back in
1993
was exclusively spatial correlation it
was done on fixed
cells we were interested in member
densities and aggregation information
today i'm going to talk about space time
correlations and how that can obtain can
be used to obtain
dynamics and information in live cell
systems
one can also do a case based spatial
fourier transform of the images before
doing time correlation
this is the case-based kicks
technique that's useful if we have
complicated
photophysics that is time dependent and
if you're interested in
varieties of methods i point you towards
this review and new journal of physics
back in 2013 by laurel aventura
at all where we basically mathematically
set up the basis of each of the methods
in illustrator
but for us today we're interested in
space-time image correlation
and i'm going to motivate that with on
the next slide
so here we have a cartoon showing an
image series taking on some type of
microscope fluorescence microscope
we would choose our region of interest
over which we're going to do
the space-time correlation we then
calculate a spatial correlation
as a function that is illustrated here
by this equation
space-time correlation function these
variables
are two spatial leg or shift variables
in terms of pixel shifts
the tau is the time lag similar to what
we have in terms of the timeline
in the fcs autocorrelation function
but here we're correlating pixel
intensities in space and time
and we're doing spatial correlation and
then
we're correlating in time in terms of
pairs
of spatial spatial correlations
this work was the work of benny baer my
first phd student in physics published
way back in 2005
and let's look at what comes out of the
spatial correlation
as a function of time for different
types of molecular behavior
so if i start this
animation of the space-time correlation
function evolving
as a function of time so we have spatial
leg spatial a
and we're displaying the evolution in
time of this function
you see that it starts off as a peak and
then
things start to decay move etc
if you have immobile molecules in your
system they will correlate in the same
space over time and you'll get a peak in
the center
if you have flowing components they will
correlate
in a given direction as a function of
time
and that will lead to the evolution of
the peak which splits off
and moves off from center and translates
this is the flow peak
that can be fit with a gaussian and
tracked
to obtain the velocity of the flow
component
if there's a diffusive component it
stays
in the center but decays and spreads
according to the diffusion law
and that can also be obtained in terms
of the fit
in terms of separating the two peak fits
today
we're interested we're going to show
applications of extracting flow
information so keep in mind
that the space time correlation is
analyzed
for the the flow peak
in the main flow peak and this is fit in
terms of the time evolution to obtain
a flow vector this slide summarizes what
i just showed in the animation
here we see a peak for a flowing
population
starts in the center and then translates
over time
we track that location over over
lag time to obtain the velocity for that
component of the flowing population
below we show a slightly more
complicated case where you have a flow
biased
diffusion peak is still translating but
note that it's decaying and spreading
uh because of the diffusion of the
population in other words this
uh both diffusion and flow happening for
this particular
system each time we would analyze
correlation function for a given region
of interest for a certain time window
repeat the process in space and time to
map
the dynamics in the cell let's look at
that in
a specific case this is turf microscopy
obtained by my
collaborator miguel in spain and we
start
with the image time series here we see
it evolving
in time and to the right
we have the mobile filtered image series
now i mentioned that in a mobile
population would contribute a peak in
the center
that would not move that obscures
our analysis of the dynamics so what we
do
is we filter in the time domain for
every pixel
and remove the lowest frequency
component that removes the static
and slowly moving components so that we
can
focus and obtain information on the
dynamics
now we would define a region of interest
actually
in practice we do it in parallel on many
regions of interest
and if we look here we see the actual
fluorescence signal for that region of
interest
and to the right was the contour plot of
the space-time correlation function
which didn't loop but i'll run it back
and we see that there's a peak moving on
from center due to flow components in
this particular region
we would fit that peak to obtain a
vector that would be done in parallel
for an iterating window through the
series and you get a time involving
vector map of the transport
in this cell resolution is not it's uh
not great on this one we'll be clear on
examples as i move forward in the
presentation and show
more research data so the first
of the research applications this is
space-time image correlation
applied in combination with super
resolution microscopy imaging structured
elimination microscopy
looking at active dynamics and membrane
organization in lymphocytes
i'm going to front load the
acknowledgements on this this was a
collaboration with dr dylan owen
and george ashdown his phd student dylan
was at king's college then he's
subsequently moved to uh university of
birmingham
elvis pancitch who was in my group as
grad student at the time
did programming of the correlation uh
space-time image correlation specific
for this
application now i mentioned this is a
super-resolution application involving
structure elimination i constantly
and i highlight on this slide the
characteristics of the reconstruction
in structured elimination microscopy and
other in other words
the illumination with grid superimposed
grid patterns which
are important in terms of obtaining
through the
magic of fourier optics the super
resolution
in sim this reconstruction
in terms of the applied grid pattern
shows up as spatial correlations in our
analysis
and it must be accounted for in terms of
filtering so we had to filter
in the fourier domain to take care of
the grid pattern
but once we did that we were still able
to do sticks on this system as i'll
illustrate so here is turf
sim microscopy uh labeled f actin in the
your cat cell
you see in the periphery you can see
retrograde
movement of the actin basically what
dylan and george did was
through basically uh immune presentation
uh generated artificial new synapses at
the periphery
of these cells you can really see the
retrograde motion there
if we look in the region we can do
in parallel on different regions of
interest space-time image correlation
spectroscopy
and there's a vector map for the actin
in this system
let's zoom in add higher detail high
resolution
and here you can see the uh the results
of parallels
sticks sticks down on many regions of
interest simultaneously
the yellow box shows the 8 by 8 pixel
region of interest that was
done for each analysis this is vastly
oversampled
each roi is shifted one pixel in each
direction
and every vector is a correlation
analysis for a time window
over an eight by eight region so you
have to move
eight vectors in any direction in uh
laterally
in order to get an independent
measurement but doing this spatial over
sampling you can really
begin to see a mapping of the actin flow
flow patterns again we had to filter
for the sim illumination pattern the
fourier domain
to properly uh extract these these uh
dynamics if you're interested this
biophysical journal letter with george
ashdown as the lead author in 2014
goes into the details of this
application
i'll just show you the time evolution of
this
here we see from the turf sim
the actin dynamics as a function of time
for iterated
sticks measurements and we can see
clearly the retrograde motion
however in this system you can actually
visually
see the retrograde act and dynamics in
the territory
system however the styx analysis allows
us to quantify aspects of velocity
distribution
and here george has basically
characterized
the angle of the retrograde actin flow
relative to
a line drawn to the cell center
and so we see a peak at zero in other
words most of the
actin is largely moving retrograde
in most of the regions that were
analyzed so one can quantify this
but you can extend further and taking a
cue from fluorescence cross correlation
straight across to be
extended to two color channels and
obtain information
on two different species at the same
time so here we're going to do
analysis in channel one green and
channel two red
and look at the interacting correlations
between two species in terms of
co-transport
and do a cross-fluctuation
cross-correlation analysis between
channel 1
and channel 2 and pick out the dance
partners
same system but now the question was
what is the retrograde actin in the
peripheral region
doing and uh dylan thought
that taking a cue from looking at
membrane domains where the actin
cytoskeleton
has been shown to have some role in
organizing proteins and nanoscale
domains
perhaps in this immune cell system
the actin is serving some sort of
organizing role in the membrane so
uh dylan and george applied for time at
genealogy farms
and research complex and used a two
color
sim church sim system there which could
operate
an image in two channels at a faster
rate and
image the same types of system your cat
t cell channel one is f
actin with the life act out of 655 label
channel two is a diode a membrane uh
a lipid analog die here we see that
again the retrograde actin movement at
the periphery where we have the
synapses generated or the artificial
ones generated
and here's the membrane dye channel two
harder to see what's going on here
with the more diffuse membrane staining
and if we superimpose the two channels
again you see the clear retrograde
acting of
motion at the periphery harder to tell
what's going on with the membrane dye
but this is where the fluctuation
analysis and correlation analysis gives
us
information of what we cannot see by eye
space-time image cross-correlation
spectroscopy shows
again in channel one the green or the
the actin channel retrograde actin flow
in the diode membrane channel we get
a net retrograde at the periphery and
the cross correlation
although noisy also shows retrograde
motion of periphery
now the noise is due to the fact that
the membrane channel
has higher concentration of label
so the fluctuations are relatively
smaller so it's a noisier measurement
but it does show up clearly here for
example we're looking at
one channel single channel analysis of
the dio lipophilic dye
region one periphery where the
artificial immune synapses are
region of interest two in the center
where we do not have them
if we characterize the angle
distributions relative to a seeded
aligned to the center of the cell we see
again retrograde
in the periphery and a more uniform
distribution
more random distribution in the center
so we clearly distinguish the two and
again this is for
the membrane channel if we analyze the
two color
image cross correlation data for the
actin
and again for a membrane dye and this
time it's die
we see a heat map of correlations or
cross correlations
the directionality is highest again at
the periphery where the artificial
immune synapses 7
generated velocity correlation
directional correlation
and not at the center the question was
then what could be linking the
retrograde actin to
the membrane in this case and
uh we thought that
actinin might be a candidate since
actinin is known to bind to
bundled actin and it's known to link
other molecules in a cell adhesion
context
so when we looked at f actin and alpha
actinin and two channel measurement
and did the cross correlation clear
retrograde
uh coordinated motion between these two
that was not surprising
but what impact would it have on the
membrane well
i'm only showing a portion of the data
that if we for the crisper knockout of
the alpha actinin
when she knocked out the alpha actinin
the coordination
of the membrane dye was
lost at the periphery when the alpha
actinin was not good
this paper by george uh ashdown at all
in by physical journal in 2017 outlines
far more in terms of the pharmacological
perturbations
more details and experiments this
highlights what can be shown
in terms of the image correlation and
revealing molecular information locked
in the images
the second research application to
finish this talk
involves looking at another type of
structure in
human immune dendritic cells and that is
called the cortisone
again front loading the acknowledgements
this is a collaboration done with
uh professor alexander comby from rabbit
university
in nijmegen in the netherlands uh a
graduate student
now in medins and dr [ __ ] vandenberg's
uh long-standing collaboration with them
and again i acknowledge
elvis my former group member who did
programming and some of the analysis
involved in this so as we switch gears
what is a protozoan well
protozoans are structures
that are involved in mechanosensation in
certain types of migratory cells
this is a time-lapse image where the
color coding shows
where protozoans and those are the
punctate structures
move as a function of time in a
migrating migrating cell
they are very dynamic lifetime of two to
twelve minutes
they're involved in extracellular matrix
degradation
they're punctate and structure and they
sh they're found in various migratory
cells myeloid cells
endothelial cells the immune dendritic
cells
in cancer cells they're called often
called
invadopodia so
we were interested in looking at the
dynamics of these structures and i'll
show why
on the next slide but there were various
models
of how the protozoans actually function
and focused on
their mechanosensory aspects here we
have
a central branched actin polymerizing at
the core
out here are integrins forming a ring
vinculin and tailing
linking to actin filaments which link
back to the core
or actin in the protozoan and myosin
to a motor proteins applying tension on
these
acting guy wires so this was the idea of
the structure back uh you know
almost almost a decade ago in terms of
this ring central actin and
tension regulated in terms of a given
codosome
but various microscopy studies and other
studies were suggesting
that the localization was not just
individual in terms of protozoa
but there was actually seem to be some
sort of regulation between protozoans so
i show you data
that was collected in alessandra's lab
by marilyn mendez
and here is it's comfortable microscopy
and we're looking at vin kill and gfp in
a 100 minute
time series each of these donuts is a
protozoan
and you can see in terms of the
fluorescence well
one the protozoans are forming and
disassembling
secondly appears that there's like waves
of
fluorescence moving between the system
as
as the protozoans form and disappear
so i went and did sticks analysis
on the data from these these types of
measurements
and you could see in terms of the vector
maps
that there was sort of like flow
patterns
which showed up in coordination with the
assembly and disassembly
of these structures again this is
regions of interest every vector is a
region of interest 16 by 16 pixels
a 10 frame window iterated through the
time on
series we saw the same patterns
in terms of vinculin as well as tailing
not too surprising given that they're
both
involved in the the uh
the ring structure the linking to the
integrand
however we also saw similar patterns
with it acting so you see
again these time evolving patterns with
the actin and this is now
imaging of life back gfp and space-time
image correlation of that
now with the actin it's a little more
complicated
because there's that core act in
polymerizing to exert the pressure
on the membrane for the mechanosensing
and then there's filaments and the
question was
are are we seeing dynamics of the
central actin filamentous actin
and all sorts of experiments were done
to show that it really wasn't
the central actin we were looking at
as well there's information coming out
uh that the protozoans were not isolated
here we see from schmidt at all electron
microscopy of the protozoan cluster we
see
filaments extending between protozoans
alexander's group
and susan cox's group also did storms
super resolution imaging and protozoans
and you can see
connections between protozoan to
protozoan protozoan
much like city city road or rail
networks
that got us thinking about how we can
correlate
between different protozoans and
elvis and i began to think about how to
do radial correlations as a function of
time
so how can we get this information out
in terms of what's going on
between different protozoans since we
already have the styx measurements
elvis suggested why not build up a pair
vector core
correlation function basically we have
vectors in different points in space and
time
from our sticks measurements calculate a
dot product between the vectors
and look at the correlation between
vectors as a function of
displacements in time and displacements
radially
if the vectors are aligned uh you would
have cos zero in the dot product
and you'll get a one they're
perpendicular
you get a zero contribution if they're
anti-parallel
you have minus one repeat this
calculation for all pairs of vectors
in space and time and build up a pair of
vector correlation map
this is radial versus time
the central area is a protozoan
correlating with itself but if we have
signal
at a given distance on time this is
telling us
about interactions between protozoans
so here i show sticks maps in terms of
like actin
and vinculin and here's the pair vector
correlation which would have been done
for a time
series again note that at zero delta r
zero delta er that's for giving codozone
and then we have it stretching in time
in terms of oscillations
we're looking at neighbor protozoans and
we can see
echoes or interactions at a distance
in this system from these correlation
measurements
and fluorescence measurements similar
measurements were seen
and observed in terms of bio afm
by a group in france published in nature
mutations in 2014
and with the fluorescence methods we saw
similar frequencies
but we were able to detect that it was a
neighbor
and next nearest neighbor coordination
that's the ozones we studied
so we proposed a model of mesoscale
coordination
of protozoans on such a surface and that
was published back in 2016 in nature
communications marilyn mendez was the
lead author on that
but subsequently kuhn and alexandra
continued to extend
using arie scan super resolution to
begin looking at this in more detail
on substrates of different stiffness so
here's a beautiful aries scan super
resolution
image done by and you can see
the actin filaments between protozoans
there's uh many things were studied
using super resolution i'm only going to
highlight the correlation aspects of
this
but basically out of these more recent
studies
we've shown that the model is a little
more complex
than was thought a decade ago and
specifically i'm going to highlight
that there are connecting actin
filaments with myosin to a
motor proteins to extend tension in
terms of the regulation over the nasal
scale
between photoshops so what happens to
finish off
on soft versus stiff substrates we see
differences
in the regulation of scale between
different protozoans
on soft versus stiff so the interaction
between neighbors
and next neighbors changes depending on
the substrate
and this is pulled out by the sticks
followed by pair vector correlation
here we have the actin paravector
correlation on the soft substrate
notice the correlation peaks over
quite a distance and on the soft
substrate
much more restricted coordination on the
muscle scale
so finish off these most recent studies
on [ __ ] random dreams paper and nature
communications last year
we have a new model of protozoan that
alessandra
likens to a cathedral
structure and that's what we were
studying
i am at the end of the talk i think
we uh i'll leave the conclusions they
can be read independently
but basically the object of this talk is
to discuss
how space time
coral image correlation could be used to
use fluctuation analysis to extract
molecular information
from a variety of systems that might not
necessarily be apparent
in just the images so it leverages the
connection
i thank you for listening i highlighted
uh the collaborations as we went along
i highlight the people involved again
here
as well as funding and i thank you for
listening today
hope everyone stays safe and enjoys the
virtual conference